the manchester city footballer benjamin
mendy accused of a series of serious sex
offenses against young women including
rape has been freed on bail by judge
patrick thompson at a hearing at chester
crown court we're going to go straight
to sky sports news correspondent peter
stevenson he's outside chester
crown court and peter was this expected
yeah i think that the judge had been
very concerned at the length of time
that this case has been taking um and as
as you say there he's been in custody
since uh last august and uh this trial
is not going to take place for another
six months yet so i think there's been
concern at the amount of time that uh
media had his co-defendant were in
custody so what's happened today is he's
been allowed out on bail he's been in
custody as i say since last august
decision made here at chester crime
court by
judge patrick thompson now that bail
comes with a really tough package of
conditions according to the judge um
mendy will have to stay at his home
address for example he can't have any
contact with the complainants in the
case and he'll have to surrender his
passport by midnight and then there's a
lot of other conditions attached that we
weren't privy to here in court today 27
year old mendy has always denied what is
now a list of eight serious sexual
offenses and of course he remains
suspended by his club manchester city
what's also happened today at this
hearing is that we've heard that two
fresh charges one of rape and one of
sexual assault have now been brought
against mendy's co-defender louis zaha
maturi he now faces a total of nine
serious offenses seven rapes and two
sexual assaults his bail application
will be considered later we've been told
today this trial is expected to last up
to six weeks and it's due to start at
the end of june
peter thanks very much